on parle pas mais où la main ça mais on
entendait bien voir on joue ensemble on
rigole ensemble de ça franchement
j'étais bien simple on pas de
découragement
[Musique]
essayez de vous concentrer et surtout
pour m'encourager
je me force à aujourd'hui je veux voir
personne qui s'engueulent je vais vous
encourager pour que début de la saison
soit les plus forts
[Musique]
autour du foot il ya une vraie
intégration sociale
ne serait-ce qu jouer avec des gens qui
ne font pas partie de leur milieu
mais aussi de jouer avec des étrangers
et ça pour nous c'était très important
[Musique]
c'est un faux pas pour moi un des pires
pluies et j'arrivais cette noble âge est
qu elle a rencontré plein de gens on se
connaît pas ça c'est une bonne idée moi
c'est trop bien mme asma ici très
content avec et voilà
[Musique]
lâche pas on n'est pas des simples coach
coach ses notes fonction principale mais
on est aussi confident amis
en tout cas proche de ces jeunes
puisqu'on un de nos moteurs est en tout
cas notre point d'orgue c'est vraiment
d'être proche des jeunes est de savoir
ce qu'ils font tous les jours c'est à
dire où est ce qu'ils vont à l'école ici
dans la rue ou pas monsieur jean claude
danglot bas pourront être motif moi de
trouver la motivation vraiment ça c'est
très important pour moi parce que là on
est arrivé en france banlieue parisienne
il a donc su retourner inscrits dans une
clope pour nous à trouver des amis on a
trouvé des traits relation pendant que
massa mais faire plaisir
[Musique]